koné un personnage sympathique dans
cette aventure c'est daniel cauchy donc
en dehors du cinéma
d'abord parce qu'on a des tas de
souvenirs nous on a connu
saint-germain-des-prés ensemble pendant
pas mal d'années et puis j'ai eu
l'impression daniel que vous avez fait
un petit peu votre traversée du désert
n'ont pas besoin désert un long désert
oui mais il y en a d'autres qui ont eu
très long désert il vous compare un
petit peu dans cette aventure à à serge
reggiani
d'ailleurs c'est assez bizarre c'est
assez étonnant de penser que vous
rencontrez toujours ensemble dans le
même bar rue saint benoît et robin buck
n'existe plus alors on parlait non non
[Rires]
alors moi ce qui m'a étonné dans votre
aventure
quand vous en avez parlé la première
fois m'avait dit j'ai une maison de
production jeudi
comment fait on quand on est comédien
qu'on est en train de traverser un
désert qu'on cherche sa voie
comment fait on pour créer une maison de
production parce que vous êtes aussi
producteur de ce film
oui mais c'est à dire que moi j'aimerais
bien continuer comme acteur j'aurais
bien voulu seulement ça manquait
d'autres l'offre à dire oui d'offres
d'acteurs alors pas en disant j'ai fait
une cinquantaine de films 12 ans ne sait
rien ce que je sais pas exactement et
peu sûr pas exactement le nombre de
films non plus puis tout d'un coup ça
s'est arrêté
pourquoi parce que j'avais un emploi
difficile j'avais je jouais toujours des
voyous toujours le même et tout d'un
coup plus rien parce que les ce que la
mode des films policiers étaient passés
est ce que la mienne était passé j'en
sais rien il a bien fallu que je trouve
quelque chose alors j'ai fait un peu
d'immobilier j'ai essayé n'importe quoi
pour trouver de l'année de l'argent pour
vivre parce que j'ai des enfants et puis
je me suis dit quand même je suis quand
même ça fait assez longtemps je suis
dans ce métier là il faut bien trouver
quelque chose dans ce métier là alors
j'ai commencé à écrire un peu avec
amadou pour une série de télévision du
reste
et puis j'ai toujours toujours voulu
faire de la production parce que ça
m'intéressait parce que parce que monter
une affaire c'est formidable et pour
pouvoir tourner les rôles qui vous
plaisait ah non pas du tout pas du tout
parce que jusqu'à maintenant même les
faits vous avez perdu
oui vous m'avez dit souvent moi j'en ai
assez de jouer les
les truands et bien vous avez votre
maison de production le premier film que
vous produisez avec vous mais c'est un
pas que je ne voulais pas m'engager
c'est molinaro qu'a voulu m'engager
moi je ne voulais pas c'est lui qui m'a
dit si je fais le film c'est avec toi
j'étais très embêté mecque pour rester
dans la lignée de vaud de vaud de votre
personnage moi je voulais plus jouer
alors peu importe je veux dire ça n'a
pas d'importance que je fasse un film où
joue un voyou maintenant quelle
importance
et pourquoi pas mais alors parce que
molinaro c'était sa condition pour
laisser son salaire dans la
participation
sinon il fallait que je le paye il est
très cher alors c'était sa seule
condition alors j'ai dit oui donc vous
récemment c'est l'année non mais ne riez
pas condamné je suis plus un acteur
l'acteur n'ont pas je suis un acteur
maintenant que les yonnais l'osella
aujourd'hui oui c'est bien ça va
continuer non ça va continuer s'ils font
gagner beaucoup d'argent on dira il est
formidable c'est le film n'a pas
d'argent on dira oui il est très bien
comme producteur donc tu nous avais
connaissez très bien joué comme ça
j'aurai beaucoup de voyous encore bas je
ne sais pas vraiment l'impression que je
serai encore beaucoup de maillots mais
un voyou très sympathique avec molinaro
parce qu'il veut pas faire de film
policier jamais il veut plus non
il voulait plus main avant ce film là il
a fait exactement parce que ça
l'intéressait aujourd'hui je me
considère pas le gaz des otages comme un
finances justement ces deux schémas
policier est un prétexte
oui à une étude un peu sociale et à une
histoire d'amour
[Musique]